[Music]
how's it gone bro
my name is Pierre back we're playing
afraid of monsters are you scared bro
you're scared you scared to watch I can
tell by your look that you're scared I'm
not scared
however I'm never scared hey magazine
clip all right good and then you bottom
to click so it's good hey buddy how you
doing
I was he supposed to scare me or
something that's what you guess bro
that's what you [ __ ] get all right um
I think I know where we're gonna go we
click the bottom right we click the
bottom yep we click the bottom now just
have to [ __ ] run past these well
[ __ ] alright it's I think it's
upstairs or downstairs okay it's
upstairs I don't think it's upstairs
don't forget posses a little hey there
Joe yes okay blue blue it's the blue
part I remember hey buddy I'm out oh you
got my back
hi Carol oh no it's not the blue area
[ __ ] that's the wrong way almost dead oh
okay oh I am good odds not one in here
how you doing how you doing Steven and
gems
ah you're dragging everywhere oh god oh
god here it is here it is urtis ha yeah
I made it how I pity not plan I do
pretty good actually I made it I'm I'm
glad you made it far penny I'm proud
Thank You mr. pan hi Betty oh yeah what
the [ __ ] is that
ha ha oh my god I need to tape this
[ __ ] camera to keep my fault lamb rod
you can hurt yourself you hurt yourself
all right I miss a battery but bat bat
bat [ __ ] is happy oh my fave oh stop
cheering me Jesus I'm dodging our kid
that's it work hey did I save that
hoppity
I was plan all right and we should same
here actually son don't let him pick up
that battery every time all right
aah aah let's dad I think I have to kill
a little [ __ ] Matt Matt Matt like
impossible this game is really [ __ ]
hard harder than my penis all right come
at me bro clapping Brown Quentin brah ah
yeah this is gonna take a while ah stop
I wish I had a gun oh wait I have the
gun all right come on brah I didn't help
chef cha cha cha cha cha cha cha cha
okay one more [ __ ] yeah ha ha ha who's
gonna [ __ ] touch oh yo yo yo yo ha ha
he thought it was tough how do I open Oh
you chomp [ __ ] move chopped up hey it's
an axe in here ok I'm just getting up
I'm just gonna go oh I want to go all
the way oh no I have to go there [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] hey there how you doing
whoo how you doing mr. Platt save me Oh
huh foot
[ __ ] stop following me aah oh there's
a clip foot odd no he got me down I was
good I was [ __ ] good
let's do that again and then go in here
all right come on buddy come on buddy
you can go uh how the [ __ ] did I go
through the other time but jump how did
I [ __ ] do it get mad
help i i'm shark steaks too much of my
IQ to get past this star I don't
understand
I don't hello penny I heard you suck
shut up plan Jesus Christ I don't talk I
know that for sure my mom told me that
yesterday she said Peter Pan Russian
talk stop just stop with it it's not
funny joke my friend I don't know app
okay I think is something bugged or
something Jesus Christ I done a lot of
time in these games all right chop it
chop top top top top top top top top top
top top top top top top
don't let me [ __ ] it in how the [ __ ] did
I do last time
chop chop chop chop chop chop chop chop
chop chop chop chop chop chop top jump
jump jump duck Duck Duck jump jump jump
jump
tuck tuck tuck tuck tuck tuck tuck tuck
tuck tuck tuck tuck tuck
wasting my flashlight clanking
[ __ ] Hannah frickin frackin top
top top top top top top top top cheese
I am crouching and I'm going in there we
go okay I'm just gonna go okay didn't go
as planned schemes too [ __ ] hard my
opinion because I jumped right I don't
remember yeah I jump hey girls
really how'd it okay let's do like I did
last time I guess try and get some ammo
huh yep yep I get it I get it
same here best place throw ever okay
come on bro come on bro [ __ ] bruh quit
bro what one shot at my head then so
it's kind of difficult yeah that I like
I wish there were some way to change the
difficulty this is way too hard I don't
know oh [ __ ] I made it oh [ __ ] I made it
let's take them oh yes die reload I'm
not gonna die from you okay good
so we got ammo I'm gonna save me a lot
of saving this playthrough okay hey girl
that up
and your day oh no I'm outta ammo mr.
mario hat
I'm not gonna die from [ __ ] Mario
character I did from a mugger okay let's
try that again and nine bullets oh well
yeah mister [ __ ] now [ __ ] okay um save
again
give that me to this fire holy [ __ ] top
top top top okay there's something about
out you backstabbing [ __ ] all right I'm
down
let me happen late Jesus Christ you're
so [ __ ] disturbing holy [ __ ]
okay he's there how do I get up there
maybe I don't even have to go here okay
I need him to come here come back brah
brah
nah but don't sit all right head up Eddy
come up here pretty it's your only
chance
oh there we go I can't break this it's
the point of this place then it's the
point of life why are we here why am i
chopping oh really really I'm gonna die
from this fall oh then this is I swear
to God is the most difficult game I ever
played in my entire life
now a lot of battery I hope there's
light in here
it's pitch dark for me can't see [ __ ]
and the batter doesn't recharge by the
way I'm playing director's cut edition
so yeah this is fun okay so we have to
redo pretty much everything that I just
stayed a lavish game love it a lab game
it's [ __ ] jump through and go for it
[ __ ] you [ __ ] you [ __ ] cha cha cha
cha cha cha cha cha cha cha ah why would
you do that do I have the gum
maybe ah I respawn here but no ammo
though hmm no ah
it's yeah I don't like you very Mitch no
sir I don't
top top top top top top top top top top
top top top top top top top okay okay
chopped up cha cha cha cha cha cha cha
cha cha go chop chop chop chop chop
okay hmm thank penis I don't know what
is this is but I'm thinking penis for it
alright save again
this [ __ ] game this is [ __ ] game
damn it started maybe I find another way
out maybe but probably not
chopped up shut up ah yeah hi dad haha
this game this game what do you want
from me take from me okay cha cha cha
cha cha cha cha cha cha cha cha cha cha
cha cha cha
oh there's a ladder here I don't want to
run out of batteries in a place like
this but I get the feeling I am will
yeah there I go yeah yeah oh my god this
game this [ __ ] game hey let's watch
PewDiePie a million times yeah yeah it's
so much fun okay in here maybe
uh-huh
holy [ __ ] what's going on here I don't
you
it's pretty cool alright let's go down
here okay this way don't want it please
don't run out of battery snap okay this
does not look good
got a saver for shizzle my stencil
dizzle all right I know what I just said
but okay here hey oh I got a shotgun you
got a problem me you talk to the shotgun
okay [ __ ]
oh this game just got a lot better
top top top top cha cha cha cha cha cha
top Oh berries I missed you hello penny
I'm a very I'm gonna help you jumper cut
them tops of traffic traffic traffic
copter top top top top top yay batteries
I mean food gap top so chapter chapter
chapter top to top the top yay
adrenaline and drugs and [ __ ] alright a
lot of pugs de villes looks like you
found the plane oh I I don't know if
it's fun to watch honestly let me know
cuz I don't enjoy playing it ELISA
sometimes I'm wrong sometimes I'm right
I don't even know I put a pile nitrogen
and if I'm just gonna enter here like
Fabian Jordan I see tomorrow
[Music]
the door won't open
all right mine oh is that creepy song
give me shivers OH
[Music]